the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good good afternoon
so in the last lecture we talked about
the remarkable human brain and out in
powers our thoughts our feelings and
desires our actions in the world and how
it began to understand it in which to
speak our feelings and thoughts that's
blocked in a patient like Broca's
patient with with Broca's aphasia we
talked about the fact that split brain
patient only to the left and right
hemispheres of the human brain mediate
separate mental abilities but they also
seem to have almost independent forms of
consciousness or don't have to be aware
of one another and some of my focus
today is to say we've really looked at
we learned from very unusual clinical
cases and I'm going to focus today on
tools we have to study the typical human
brain and and what is it that we can do
to understand how your brain and you
know without having a hemispherectomy or
a big stroke how does it operate and
what are the principles of human brain
function that give rise to the human
mind so so waters the ways we can learn
about the human brain and one thing we
can't do is what animal researchers can
do right that we can literally go inside
the brain except in rare very rare
clinical situations I'll talk about them
but that's a rare source of evidence so
there's a million ways in which I
understand which part of the brain does
which part of the mind and we talked
about the fact that you know phrenology
was a sort of a big misstep in assigning
mental life the functions of mental life
but different parts of the brain and so
we hope we can do a bit better than that
and I'm going to review with you today
some of the core methods and there's a
number of them so for studying human
brain the reason there's a number is
none of them get our sort of the magic
answer all of them are limited in their
own ways and we sort of need all of them
to begin to grasp how your brain makes
your mind there's three huge ways in
which we know how the human brain is
organized lesions and injuries to the
brain stimulation when you're allowed to
stimulate the brain rarer but we'll talk
about that and the most common that
you see all the times in books and
magazines recording functional MRI EEG
methods where we record brain activity
and try to understand how that relates
to the life of the human mind and so
we're going to go through these things a
little bit and you know show you how
they're applied in some ways that I hope
that you'll find interesting we'll come
back to many of these things as we go
through the semester and as we talk
about aging or child development or
personality or other topics social
cognition will come we'll use these
tools to understand the brain basis of
those kinds of aspects of our mental
lives so what's a big injury you can
have you can have a stroke where we're
at issue in the brain no longer receives
its vascular supply that it depends on
so greatly and a lot of different things
like hypoxia a lack of oxygen the brain
is very sensitive to oxygen tumors can
grow you can have degenerative disorders
like Alzheimer's Huntington's
Parkinson's and others epilepsy so
there's lots of different ways in which
you can end up with brain injury and
ultimately neuronal death so what's the
strength of this form of evidence well
first of all it's causal we've talked
about the difference between causal and
correlational sources of evidence causal
ones be more powerful for scientific
explanation a certain part of the brain
is injured and you no longer can speak
you change your character you no longer
can make memories we're pretty sure that
part of the brain in some way is
required or causal for that part of your
mental life to operate the deficits you
see following brain injuries can be
amazing we talk about Phineas Gage
changing this character unable to
produce language unable to make new
memories we'll talk a little bit about
patients with post a big nose yeah it's
a good big word to go home on spring
break and if your parents ask you what
have you learned about you say
prosopagnosia right that just means a
deficit in recognizing faces patients
with prosopagnosia will be unable to
recognize their own spouse by their face
they'll recognize it by the voice by the
physical movements but not by their face
we learn amazing things about the brain
that you know until it happens we didn't
know they could happen what people like
to call counterintuitive so we'll talk
later and of course in a couple times
about blindsight patients who say I see
nothing but their behavior shows some
part of the brain sees something we'll
talk about category specific deficits
where patients
all of a sudden can no longer name
living things but they can name
nonliving things okay so you wouldn't
have thought of that if you didn't see
that and we get separations in the brain
between different things we talked about
the difference between the left
hemisphere being important for local
features the right for global the left
thinking in terms of functional things
in the world the right thing in terms of
appearances we talked about that already
we'll talk about other things that the
hippocampus is important for knowing
that knowing a piece of information but
the basal ganglia is important for
learning how to do things mental skills
and physical skills we'll come back to
all of those so it gives us this way to
organize things so much of our most
solid understanding of the human brain
still comes from the history of
neurology and lesions well what are its
limitations first brain injuries you
know don't follow anatomical boundaries
they sort of cross over things depending
on the injury so they're not going to
selectively damage one part of the brain
and not touch an adjacent one that could
be doing something different people can
be variable in the response nearby
systems if you have two things in the
brain that are next door to one another
do quite different things
injuries are likely to injure them both
and you will wrongly conclude have a
wrong conclusion about the or
architecture of the human brain when we
test a patient and ask them to do things
after a brain injury we don't really
test the part of the brain that's not
there we really test a part of the brain
that is there people do the best they
can
so there's secondary degeneration to an
injury there's recovery from an injury
there's compensation from an injury when
you test a patient with a brain injury
you're testing what the rest of the
brain can do in the absence of one of
its partners one of its companions and
finally can offer a limited views of
normal brain function let me pick one
and we'll come back to this in the
course we're very interested in
variation in people individuality
what's the neurology of individuality
that's very hard to study in lesion
cases because we don't see enough of a
lesion we don't have enough Phineas
gages to ask with that injury looked
different if you grew up in one culture
or another if you were outgoing versus
shy those kinds of things are very hard
to answer you know a patient by patient
but we can test large groups of people
with imaging and ask what is the
influence of culture
on your brain organization what's the
influence of personality on how your
brains organized and you'll see later on
in the semester evidence about those
sorts of things so let's go back to Paul
Broca the the neurologist who you know
it gave the name to Broca's area because
he saw a patient like this like but can
that this patient had a big injury in
this area and can no longer speak and
every course you ever take about the
brain almost will include a discussion
about Broca's area so I'm gonna warp
your world in a very narrow way but it
may be a shockingly tell you we don't
even know how to think about Broca's
area once we get more scientific than
that okay so this is MIT so we're
willing to tell the truth okay so some
years later nina dronkers did the
following thing she studied a large
group of patients who are had Broca's
aphasia by behavior that is they you
know trouble speaking but their
comprehension was pretty good and then
she made maps of their injuries and she
over laid those maps and she said who
has Broca's aphasia and if you have
Broca's aphasia what's the one part of
the brain that every patient with
Broca's aphasia has damage to because
these patients what you see on these
maps is you know some patients have
damage here or here or here but you line
them all up and you say what's the one
spot that you have to have injured to
have Broca's aphasia and it's not this
area that you saw in the picture it's
this area in yellow an area called the
precentral gyrus of the insula the
insula is a fascinating mysterious
little structure you have one on the
left and one on the right that runs
along from the temporal lobe up to the
frontal cortex just a couple years ago
there was a paper reporting that
patients who had stroke and posterior
insula instantly gave up smoking and
never wanted to smoke again there's huge
research efforts to help people quit
smoking is because it's such a difficult
health problem okay these patients it's
not nobody's doing insula lesions to
help people stop smoking okay but it
just stopped there is the smoking and
their desire to smoke just like that
those are now more towards the front of
the brain this is not what anybody in a
book or a course will tell you is
Broca's area that's out here but it
turns out this is the hotspot and you
could say well what about the original
patient so kind of creative
nina dronkers went back and they did an
MRI of the brain of the deceased
original brook as a physical patient
okay
they still had his brain they put it in
a scanner and they ran an out structural
MRI and what they found was sure enough
he had damaged way inside the the
exterior limit of his damage as well as
in white matter that connects to it so
even now imaging evidence lets us
rediscover what is the true main basis
of your ability to speak or its
vulnerability to injury and it turns out
not to be exactly what Broca was thought
it was see he saw a big lesion and he
said this is the part that matters it
turns out as far as we understand it's a
slightly different part that he thought
was just at the edge and not important
so we can get better even going back a
hundred and fifty years of imaging a
brain we don't have many of those brains
around stimulation so you like to go in
the brain and stimulate people who do
animal work will go and it's stimulate a
neuron and see what happens it's rare
you only get in to the patient's brain
when they have something when they have
a neurosurgical procedure and they're
considering a resection and removal of
tissue you can also do recordings by
putting grids on top of those brains and
Penfield it famous studies for patients
with epilepsy who you know where he
would stimulate and map things it
contributed a lot to our thinking about
the brain but that's a rare source of
evidence as you can imagine another one
that's much more common there's one of
these devices down the streets in
building 46 is transcranial magnetic
stimulation or TMS so this is one in
which people are allowed a and
responsibly to give you a virtual lesion
for a few moments okay if you volunteer
to do so so they put a some sort of wire
there's different configurations over
your head in a targeted location it
generates a magnetic field that passes
through the skull and introduces a
current and what happens is the current
drives lots of neurons to fire turns out
this is kind of interesting if all your
neurons are firing at the same moment in
one sense is it that none of them work
because there's no information right
there's a lot of different ways you
could think about that but for example
if I'm you're 300 channel television
that all the channels on simultaneously
on the same screen it wouldn't be very
easy to watch okay something like that
all the neurons firing is pretty much
wipes out the function at that area
people do you know do feel a little bit
of a physical sensation if you're prone
to epilepsy it's not a good idea to try
this so it does require some careful
supervision experimentally but you can
do this with healthy people and if for
example you do it on this side of the
motor cortex people will twitch or say
they felt somebody touched them nobody
touched them but the part of their brain
that codes for touch just got turned on
if you put it on the occipital cortex of
visual cortex and you turn it on at a
certain moment you can put a word up and
a word down and the person will say they
saw nothing you'll make them
functionally cortically blind for a few
moments okay so people have done
experiments like this to suppress
activity to enhance activity sometimes
it makes people even faster like naming
pictures and it's also been used they're
still experimental studies of whether it
can be helpful for treatments of
neuropsychiatric disorders so it's
non-invasive in a sense of you're not
going literally inside you have a causal
thing because you're turning the brain
on or off it's not very well targeted it
can't go into subcortical areas but it's
a very interesting tool so let's talk
about recording brain structure for a
moment so it's really important to
separate this concepts between recording
structure which is a picture of anatomy
or function which is a picture of
physiology so there's old ones
angiography and things like that I'll
show you two computed tomography and M R
and a really cool measure called
diffusion tensor imaging and then
there's functional measures and we'll
talk about those EEG pet fMRI Meg so
here's some different images you can get
from the brain so here's what a brain
would look like roughly speaking
actually this is a post-mortem brain
this is a cut brain here's the front
here's the back if a brain was open in
front of you this is what you would see
so here's an MRI magnetic resonance
imaging and it's pretty good you can and
I'll show you but some more pictures in
showing you lots of information not as
good as if you were in there but pretty
good here's a CT scan computed
tomography you know it's not as good as
more blurry and this thing that looks
really sad right it looks like like you
get your camera focus right that's
actually the quality of the picture that
we see that underlies maybe the most
widely use tool these days for
understanding the human
brain functional magnetic resonance
imaging it's a very smudgy picture but
it has some really interesting
properties so here's the kind of thing
you go into for an MRI but structural or
functional and some of you have almost
certainly been participants in research
or experiments or studies stick up your
hand if you have just like a lot of you
okay so you'll you'll speak up on this
is it quiet or noisy it's super noisy
okay so uh you know so you have to have
earplugs in and if you're doing this and
this is why people doing experiments
with functional MRI want to do visual
studies because auditory ones are tricky
so Tyler your head Tia Alexa auditory
stuff it's ten times harder to pull off
those experiments everybody tries to do
visual stuff so you don't have the noise
problem but you get some beautiful
pictures so here's here's computed
tomography and here's an MRI structural
scan from the brain the ventricles
here's basal ganglia so you could see
that with the MRI beautifully you can
see the cortical the difference between
white and gray matter I'm always
impressed that the gray matter is just
this thin ribbon I mean cortex really
means bark it's just like the bark on
our tree right and when you look at the
brain this way look at how much white
matter there is yours your frontal
cortex look at all that white matter and
then this thin cortical mantle or ribbon
or bark that's you know what we think of
as a smarts of language and social
planning and things like that
so that's a structural picture okay and
then these pictures are sort of fund you
see them let's see this is just recorded
down the street just we're gonna fly
through your brain okay here we go maybe
from one year to the other and amazing
resolution it's not the same thing like
being inside the brain there's things
that you don't see we know that but you
see a lot it's not cool so um let's
examine you know what you can see now
that we used to have to wait only about
40 years ago you would have to have a
person die to see this so this is a
patient with Huntington's disease we'll
come back and talk about that disorder
here's a healthy person top of the brain
this is a caudate here part of the basal
ganglia and you can see now a patient
has passed away that part of the brain
is completely withered away in
Huntington's disease you would have to
wait till a person passed away to see
something like that but with modern
imaging here's a healthy person top of
the brain again lining the ventricles as
the caudate and here in a living
Huntington's patient so you can see the
great withering of the way some of
cortex - in later stage of the disease
but especially in the basal ganglia
here's a healthy older person about 70
years of age top of the brain bottom of
the brain the ventricles here's on the
left and the right of the hippocampus
the structure we'll talk about without
which you cannot learn any new fact or
remember any event in your life okay any
new events are so powerful for almost
every sense of learning and look what
happens to that structure can same aged
patient with with Alzheimer's disease
it's virtually gone it's greatly
withered you see it's much wider here
because it's tissues greatly shrunk and
in the Alzheimer's patient so we can see
these kinds of changes in living people
both for research purposes and clinical
purposes here's one that's more cheerful
and more reflecting your experience so
here are studies of brain changes from
age 4 to 21 so they follow people a
large number of people at NIH from age 4
to 21 and what this shows is this color
coding is the thickness of the cortex
and you might imagine that as you get
older and smarter and go through grade
school and middle school in high school
and MIT College and as you head towards
grad school your brain will get thicker
and thicker with cortex it's exactly the
opposite ever since you have about 5
years old you've been shedding
by the millions okay by them and
connections among them by the trillions
and you're still gonna do that until
you're probably about 22 or 23 then you
peek and you decline and become faculty
members alright okay so but that's kind
of really interesting we'll come back to
this that what happens as your brain
gets smart experienced knowledgeable all
the differences between you now if
you're 8 17 18 19 20 and when you were 4
it all goes with your cortex getting
thinner and we'll come back to that and
how people think about that but let's
see if I can give this next movie to run
so there's also an ordering and we'll
come back to this but I want to show you
this movie so the more blue you are the
thinner you are the more advanced you
are in terms of ultimate young adult
development
here's visual cortex vision coming in
this is somatic motor cortex how you
feel your body and how you move your
self and what you're see is as you go
from age 4 to 21 the blue spreads that's
spreading is your brain maturing in
higher thought areas okay so we're gonna
review your life on average right now
here you go
and now you're ready to graduate okay
all right okay it's kind of a amazing
story
a fantastic brain changes that move you
from every what you could do and not do
it for to what you can do and not do at
age 21 and you know we couldn't see
these things we couldn't begin to see
these things until it just a few years
ago in any scientific sense I mean all
these things were like miraculous
sources of information so let's pick
another thing and we'll tie it to school
work and then here's the structure we
said the hippocampus so important for
the formation of new memories on an
everyday basis everything that's
important and that you learn so here's a
fun study they took unless you hear it
think about a scientific limitation but
it's fun you know as students to think
about that they looked at students in
medical school in Germany they looked at
the a measure of anatomic thickness of
the hippocampus before and after they
like crazy for a huge exam okay over at
some number of periods so here's the
before picture and the after this is the
difference between the two sorry and
what they're showing you is that B as
you study your hippocampus got thicker
as you crammed for your tests right so
you know will there be a day where
instead of having to give you tests we
could just measure the thickness of your
hippocampus and know how much you study
didn't you could just here zoom in and
out of a scanner I don't know but one
cool thing about is is showing you that
we can see structural changes not just
on a giant scale from from when you're
four to twenty-one but from some number
of months of experience we can see a
physical change in your brain now that's
trivial for animal researchers they can
show amazing things in seconds okay but
to see the human brain physically
changing so let's take a look another
one slightly more controlled we'll look
at two more examples London taxicab
drivers now if you traveled in various
cities and encountered various taxis you
may have had better and worse
experiences whether the taxi driver
knows where he or she is going exactly
London is famous for having a very high
code taxi drivers have to take big exams
to get their official taxi license okay
so they're there they had they they they
they create a very demanding thing and
where they asked is the hippocampus if
you learn lots of routes if you know
tons of routes in London what happens to
the hippocampus is its memorizing all
these spatial routes and when they show
that taxi drivers have bigger hippocampi
and the long and the longer they drove
the bigger it was so is this a causal or
correlational source of evidence
it's correlational right you know so
let's start with this they have a bigger
hippocampi and now maybe that's simply
because what maybe somebody is an
awesome hippocampus is ready to go to be
a taxi driver right maybe they pass the
test they said I'm an awesome time and
the one who got lost all the time was
driving to the wrong Airport and stuff
small hippocampus never became a taxi
driver right so now the size of the
hippocampus is a cause of your success
not the consequence because the longer
you drove the bigger it got that kind of
goes with that you know that but we
could do they could you could do a
causal experiment this way they taught
people to juggle three balls they
practiced every day for three months
three months juggling every day
what you see in yellow are parts of the
brain that's a statistical you know map
parts of the brain that significantly
got thicker in three months of practice
they could compare directly before and
after it's a causal experiment and these
are areas that are involved in visual
motion and it makes sense that areas
involved in visual motion would somehow
change but the fact that we can see
three months of experience change the
structure of your brain it's kind of
remarkable in a way that we can measure
and scientifically scrutinize you might
be curious if you did three months of
this and you were a pretty good juggler
you're impressing your friends at
parties you're brain scan is different
right what do you think happened they
followed these people up after the drug
gluing requirement stopped they kind of
stopped most of the people they kind
weren't bad they were too busy they
would show off here and there but that
was it they measured their brains again
about six months later and this change
was gone it came in and it went out with
the activity
okay so activity dependent so depending
on what you do you could think about
every activity you do the mental and
physical that you do is constantly
slightly changing your brain and if you
do a lot of it you're fundamentally
changing it like in these individuals
but if you stop doing it you go right
back to where you were because you're
going to be doing something else and
another fun measure that's kind of
beautiful and intriguing is diffusion
tensor imaging now everything we've
talked about so far has been grey matter
of the brain the neurons and the
circuits they form we're going to turn
to white matter which is the myelinated
axons that are the super conducting sort
of highways of the of the brain and what
diffusion tensor imaging does it shows
you something about the organization of
that white matter measuring directly the
movement of water at very very tiny
distances so this is a cross-section of
a myelinated nerve fiber those are the
fibers that are covered with a white
matter that have to go some distance and
the myelin protects the quality and
speed of that signal through your brain
and you can see at the level of if
you're a tiny tiny drop of water or
smaller than that this is a pretty big
bump in the road okay so imagine your
little drop of water moving a little bit
and you bump up against the myelin you
go can't go that way and you go back
this way
you go with the flow you go parallel
with the myelin it's hard to cross it at
that microscopic scale but we can
measure that movement in areas where
it's highly constrained the that's the
property of the water
here's cerebral spinal fluid things can
go anywhere she's aware there's a lot of
white matter and the water tends to flow
along parallel with the white matter
just for physical reasons it can't cross
it over and here for example is a
statistical map comparing this measure
of white matter organization between
adults who either in their childhood had
a diagnosis of dyslexia reading was
difficult for these individuals or
people who had typical reading
development where reading was you know
you learned to read and it wasn't
particularly difficult and you can see
that in this area around the temporal
parietal cortex there's a significant
difference but when we look we can do
one more thing
these are reading scores this way this
is the measure of the white matter
organization from the diffusion tensor
imaging each of these is an individual
person now so the open dots are the
people who had typical reading
development the filled dots are the
people who had a poor development and
you can see it's pretty continuous even
in the people with the open circles who
never had a problem the better they read
the more the organization is here okay
so this is not just a difference between
good and bad readers it's a difference
between people who are really good
readers and medium readers and poor
readers right continuous so now cause or
effect were those of you who had three
who had awesome myelin where you going
readings a snap I love this stuff you
know where's Warren peace mom right okay
or or were you like two jugglers and you
were X you were reading a lot and you
were exercising was part of the brain
and you altered its physical structure
and the answer is we don't know
how could we know how could we know if
you if you were scientists and we're
given a pot of money to do this how
could you know well yeah
yeah do a longitudinal study and start
like before people read right and you
could see what is it different then you
know other people are we born to be big
readers or by being big readers do we
alter this that could not do
architecture of our brain you know
what's the effort and what's the talent
so what's the predisposition at birth
and what's the time you put in in
creating this part and we don't know
that yet but you know we have a place to
look at that and then you can create
these kinds of beautiful pictures and
I'll say word about this so this is an
individual person's white matter
organization so we could take this
picture of you or anybody you know who
wants to go on a scanner and what you
sculler coded are in blue our fibers
that are running up or down we can't
tell whether the fibers which direction
they're going kind of but we can tell
they're their orientations up and down
look left and right in red up and down
in blue and green is front to back
unless you're really pretty cool huh I
can tell you that I'll say where it goes
she will do that again I like it but I
work in this area so I mean it's a
fantastic there's an individual persons
white matter organization I mean you
know as information is flowing around in
your mind here's the paths that it's
flowing around it and as you just do
anything that's interesting in your and
your feelings or thoughts right it's
fantastic I can tell you that the the
algorithms that are used to create these
maps there's some debate about the
better ones okay so the last steps of
this are a bit debated in a bit
depending on the how cool you are as a
as a visual engineer alright but there's
a lot of things that's right about
diffusion tensor imaging so it's it's a
lot of things are right about it okay so
function so you know most of all we're
interested structure not just for itself
but how it makes your mind do the things
you can do and when we think about
different functional measures that are
available to neuroscientists or
psychologists you know we often think in
two dimensions spatial resolution and
temporal
solution how precise are we where we are
and you know what's a time scale that
we're measuring in you know millisecond
are we averaging over as many seconds
many hours we know mental operations
roughly speaking occur at the
millisecond level or maybe 10
milliseconds it's there's no answer to
that but we know lots of things happen
that fast in the mind so as you look at
this here you can see that for example
if you're an animal work looking at size
you can get down to the synapse or the
dendrite we can't touch that in humans
we can't touch that cellular stuff and
it's not until we get up to here you
know which is like big patches of the
brain that we can state things about
people that's why it's always going to
be fundamental in neuroscience there's a
link the human work to the animal work
because we can't get to the neurons or
anything like that in a person almost
ever all right that has to come from a
gnome or where you can do invasive work
so we have to look at pretty big patches
of the human brain how about time well
we can get down to milliseconds in time
in the human brain functional things
like pet and MRI are here and the order
of a multiple seconds I'll come back to
this but you can see all these things
have strengths now you don't always want
to be down to a single synapse it's not
clear that we would understand much of
the organization brain at the level of a
synapse
okay there's things happening synapse
but I think like knowledge or love or
something like that probably we can't
study at the level of the synapse
effectively yet bigger units are
probably more interpretable so here's a
fun one EEG z' electroencephalography so
they put on your head some sort of a cap
with electrodes and they measure changes
in an electrical activity that are being
picked up through the skull and there's
you're picking up huge changes in
hundreds thousands of neurons but you're
able to do it
millisecond by millisecond at the speed
of thought and the same kind of signals
roughly used for e the same electrical
signal for EEG and ERP that evoke
responsible tential with EEG as you just
watch it over time so you can see these
different rhythms that go with a person
in coma or a deep sleep asleep drowsy
relaxed you can see these sort of
characteristic rhythms that people can
measure if you do an experiment
you can time lock these you know moment
by moment to some stimulus or task you
give the person so here we're gonna time
lock these and then you get a thing like
this that says here's a response you
know maybe the first moment after I see
a word or the second moment after I see
a word or something like that so you can
time lock lot electrical responses in
the brain and you get some studies like
this and we'll come back to this but
here's and here's a fun one in language
for example you read a sentence like you
see it it was his first day at work okay
that's the baseline condition in purple
not a particularly exciting sentence
okay although your first day at work is
actually pretty interesting but not to
read a sentence isn't right how about
this one he spread the warm bread with
socks
you know socks I'm shocked that makes no
sense at all right what happens as you
read it here's a broken blue line you go
whoa and that's called the n400 okay but
that's kind of cool
you know that's 400 milliseconds after
you saw that word you said
I get it socks but it doesn't make sense
okay so you're violating semantics are
common and then they have to do a
control experiment and a lot of
psychology and in a course like this we
can't devote enough time to this but I
can tell you high-quality researchers in
psychology as high quality
thoughtfulness like in any other field
you could say well maybe it's not the
word socks us bothering Mayhew maybe
it's just because it's hot just like I'm
weird it's like a weirded out signal
okay it's a weirded out signal so they
do they do this she put on her
high-heeled shoes but they put shoes at
big print that you didn't expect okay so
now you're weirded out but it makes
sense so what happens in your mind you
have a very different response here so
here the meaning is wrong here the size
is wrong and so you can read a person's
mind in this sense millisecond by
millisecond if they understand something
like a sentence you can do it with
babies which is pretty cute okay and and
as exciting too right so we can measure
it in the millisecond it's very lots of
people can take doing it it's relatively
inexpensive what's why don't we just run
around and do that and we do that at MIT
and lots of places do this too well its
spatial resolution is really problematic
we don't know where in the brain the
signals are really coming from we know
where the electrode is on the head but
that's picking up a lot of stuff below
it we don't know where and the brain is
coming from you know the way I think
about a little bit imagine
you went to a football game and you're
on the outside of the stadium and you
heard big cheering on the side that you
knew as MIT you might figure something
good happen to MIT then you hear big
cheering on the side where the Caltech
teams and you know sitting in there's
fans right it may be the usual Rose Bowl
and a and you know you might feel
because something good happen at Caltech
but you don't really know exactly what
happened in exactly where it happened
right so we don't know where the signals
are coming from in a very precise way
there's another method that's sort of
very intriguing to and we're just
installing that at MIT and you could be
amongst the first generation of
participants if you so choose to do this
is called magnetic encephalography
active neurons produce small magnetic
fields you can use a superconducting
quantum device to measure this tiny tiny
changes in the magnetic field they're
secondary to the neurons firing these
signals are problematic to measure
occurs they're submitted to be a hundred
million times smaller than the Earth's
magnetic field that in all these
measures we have of human brain function
all of them
the signal is terrible compared to the
noise
it's terrible computer than it's okay
and mega it might be the worst okay
there's a number of places that
installed Meg and had to take it out
because the local traffic on the road
was too big relative to the difference
between the Earth's magnetic field in
the signal they get signal to noise is
terrible and every non-invasive human
brain measure we have but you get
something beautiful now any mental
thought we have of any interest of any
kind
we pretty much understand to be the
property not of a single part of the
brain doing its thing but a remarkable
concert of different parts of your brain
playing or interacting with one another
okay it's a symphony orchestra doing
anything interesting in the human mind
and Meg can show that beautifully so
here's an individual's structural MRI
that's been inflated they sort of blown
it out like a balloon okay so that's
sort of easy to look at and what you're
going to see now from Dale Hale grand is
an M eg measurement millisecond by
millisecond of what your brain does
roughly speaking when you read a single
word okay here we go
see back and forth back and forth
there's all this interaction feeding
forward from when you see it feeding
backward from parks you brain said I
think I know what it is let's double
check okay
back and forth back and forth let me do
one more times I think it's just so cool
okay anything interesting that your
brain does is a incredibly complicated
millisecond by millisecond interaction
between large-scale brain networks so
here we go again reading a single word
comes arrives in the back of the brain
fronts thinking about back front back
front back front ooh
we read the word okay or you know so uh
it's just amazing an emmy gee - butters
for us to see this time-based way in
which your mind accomplishes things very
it's very the strengths are is great
temporal resolution a non-invasive
spatial resolution is maybe better than
the EEG or perhaps better not as good as
fMRI we'll come to that and it only can
measure neurons in the cortex that are
parallel to the skull so we can't see
lots of things like subcortical
structures like the hippocampus ok so
now we're moving to the measures that
you most often see but these other ones
are all help us along and they they're
all derived from the following things
sadly for pet or fMRI the most widely
used studies to understand how your mind
works
we can't interrogate the neurons that
compute your mind we can they're off
balance to us ok the other measures you
just saw are based on neurons what we
have to do is we have to look for
gossipy neighbors that is the
vasculature that surrounds and supports
the neurons that compute the mind and we
know that the neurons require oxygen and
glucose metabolically to do their work
right their cellular life and the brain
area is active there's increased blood
flow and increased energy supplies that
come to that so it's all the sort of
inference by the secondary consequence
of neurons doing their business so the
brain is about three and a half pounds
is about two percent of your total body
mass so it has a tenfold 20 percent
extra demand of body oxygen your brain
cries out for oxygen at every moment so
two percent of your body but 20% of the
oxygen demand and it's so sensitive that
only 10 minutes of loss of oxygen will
can often cause irreversible brain
damage especially in structures like the
hippocampus
now the first discovery that blood
changes that are going with brain
changes blood changes that are there
sort of the echoes if you will as
secondary consequence can be measured it
was low-tech compared to recurrent
machines this is work from Angelo mosso
in the late ta titties and he saw a
patient who had a unusual sort of
malformation so he had almost no skull
here okay and he put on it something
that measured the pressure there and he
know and he also measured and what's
shown here in red is this pressure and
as a control thing it's pretty clever he
measured pulses of blood in the forearm
so those are in blue okay that's the
control that's not just blood everywhere
and what he did is the guys sitting
there and nothing happening and he
noticed that when the church bells rang
nearby boom this device picked up
increased pressure over this part of the
head that's pretty cool it has to be
blood it's not neurons okay it's blood
okay but now he has the signature of
mental life in your brain the blood
consequence of a thought which is I hear
the church then he asked the guy does it
have to be something that you hear he
says did you make your prayers to do
your Abba Maria again nothing happening
peripherally but boom as he gives his
answer I changed in blood pressure there
or do math problem boom a change there
okay so all of a sudden blood changes
over part of the brain become the
witness to that part of the brain
supporting the mental operations to do
that task and here's a pet studies the
first waged positron emission tomography
which basically used a measured local
brain activity by looking at the
consequences of photons disintegrating
as they're measured and this sort of a
device and here's the way they use this
task to discover which parts to map the
neural organization of the human mind so
I need somebody who's comfortable who's
willing to do a task at their seat it's
just gonna be reading words or coming up
with words okay thanks okay um here you
go ready look at that in our field we
call that fixation you're just looking
okay just looking alright good job okay
ready for something else all right
now just look at these things okay you
see the words the technical word is
reading okay all right now imagine we
did one more thing with you and actually
if you were in a PET scan or here's what
would happen if in a PET scanner you'd
be sitting down there like that there'd
be a physician you know in a lab coat
like this there'd be a physicist in the
basement making up some sort of a tracer
they're going to inject into you every
every round of this okay that and
because that's what they need to
subtract this and it comes up an
elevator and people take turns running
down the hall with it because it has a
pretty short half-life the shortness of
its half-life is what makes it you able
to do these multiple measures okay this
is a pretty big deal of process and in
fact the one or two pet sessions I ever
attended you would rotate who would run
down the field with a radioactive
substance so you would share the
radioactive substance okay so anyway so
you've done that okay so now you've done
that and you feel like I'm doing pretty
good so now they come and they say are
you ready for another injection they
have something a catheter running into
your arm and they inject you again here
comes the radioactive stuff the oxide
okay
and now they're gonna ask you to read
the words aloud presenting one at a time
whoops but when you just read them aloud
one more time go ahead okay and they say
thank you very much we can do one more
injection if that's okay with you of
radioactive substance okay and now we're
going to do one thing and this this is
harder as you see each word tell us a
verb that describes what you might do
with that object or what a person might
use so go ahead for Rose tell us perfect
okay yeah I can tell you that the
experiment that person a lot ease in the
last subjects after awhile just go use
use use use okay hold hold hold oh all
right but you did a good job okay so so
here's what they say this is just
looking at something this is looking at
a word which is reading now don't forget
we're the only species that ever read
okay reading this pot had been around in
our culture only for about seven hundred
years on any scale and reading is an
uncredible thing to read a word
correctly and you saw the whole brain
flicker to get it right but now you're
gonna say the word in the next condition
so you're not just looking at the word
but you're also saying it and now
finally you're not only saying a word
and looking at it but you're thinking
about it to come up with smell or pet
right so they say what we're going to do
is we're going to
do a hierarchy of your mind just looking
reading reading and talking reading and
talking and thinking and by comparing
those different conditions will subtract
them against each other
and pull out the part of your mind that
sees a word that speaks a word and that
thinks about a word and will separate
those out in the brain so it's basically
the subtraction method so when we
compare looking at fixation versus
looking at words we'll see what part of
your brain discovers that it's a word
knows how to read words looking at words
versus repeating them will discover the
basis of speech speaking in word versus
coming up with the verb thinking about
stuff their meaning and coming up with
an answer so again the idea is if you're
saying something like you know pet for
the cat you're doing all these things or
you might just be reading it aloud and
we'll subtract them now in both these
conditions here you saw a word and read
it here you saw a word and came up and
produced a verb you subtract these two
and you end up with a statistical image
like this this is not a raw image of
blood all these figures you ever see
those are statistics of areas that
differ by some statistical criterion
between one condition other than all
statistics they're not blood or raw
blood that underlies it but what you see
is a statistic and here's the statistic
now in both of these cases you saw the
word in this case you simply read it in
this case you read it in your head and
you came up with a verb why don't we see
anything back here why don't we see the
seeing of the word even though the
seeing occurred in both conditions why
don't we why isn't it visible in this
brain picture because it's been
subtracted out okay so always in these
brain imaging experiments for reasons
I'm about to tell you we almost always
have to do some kind of subtraction now
I'll tell you why okay but that
subtraction is very big because what you
subtract out that's the heart of the
experiment okay your decision about
what's a legitimate subtraction and the
reason we have to do it is this look at
these two things here's one condition
and here's the other condition do you
see there they look pretty similar okay
again signal-to-noise your brain is busy
all the time
okay now we asked you to do something
and see the difference and the
difference is very tiny by the way we
measured it's not tiny mentally it's not
tiny in terms of the consequences for
civilization in the world okay it's tiny
because of the weird way we have to
measure it all right so I can tell you
that if if you if I put on an optimal
checkerboard this psycho physicists have
said this is super this turns on your
visual cortex I'll get about a three to
five percent change in your brain signal
if you wave your arm I can get three to
five percent signal change in your
cortex here if I ask you to do
everything between seeing something and
moving your lips your hand
everything about thought emotion memory
desire motivation everything that's big
in our life we'll get something like
1/10 of 1% of a signal change 1/10 of 1%
of a signal change okay so is that
Tyler's like oh yeah cuz yeah that means
you have to test a lot of subjects and
work 40 years on your PhD all right so
uh so we have to do that subtraction
because if we just take a picture of
what's going on in your head it's so
much that we can't tell what's going on
at all and if we happy to do something
that's pretty big like seeing like a
really provocative picture we'll just
get a tenth of one percent of a signal
change so we have to do the subtraction
to have a hint and then we do one other
weird thing we don't have to but we
often do it we want to average people to
make some general statement about
humanity as far as we can do it based on
the 10 MIT students we test okay
and so we scrunch everybody's brain into
a common space everybody's brains a
little bit different like their bodies
are a little bit different we scrunch
everybody to line them all up so we have
a common physical space so by the time
you see this picture it's a statistic on
an average of people in most cases but
you get an amazing story which up until
these pictures
some years you know about now in the
late 1980s it was unimaginable that you
could go inside a living person's brain
and see what it is that allows you to
hear a word in auditory cortex to see a
word in visual cortex to move your mouth
to speak or to think what's a verb that
goes with that word okay
unimaginable you know at your okay now I
have to do the quick math but you'll
help me yeah what year were you born in
eighty to ninety two I know you've got
my age at all plans believe ninety-two
okay so just a year or two before you
were bored and this was a five years
before you weren't unimaginable that you
could see such a picture you know when I
was a graduate student at Harvard and
the people at Washington st. Louis
University who did the first of these
did an incredible service to the field
here we saw my gosh it was like landing
on the moon going inside the human brain
canoeing which part of the brain and
douses with with human capacities now we
can be appreciative over we can be
skeptical scientists and we can say this
let's pick this one
let's compare seeing a seeing a word
like board versus seeing a fixation we
do that subtraction and that's seeing a
word just by common sense what's wrong
with this comparison it's okay it's not
terrible
how could you control a debtor to
understand what this part of the brain
is really doing I heard something well
partly it's a meaningful word versus
something that doesn't mean anything to
us right but what else could you do say
it's different between them yeah
in this case oh my gosh yes I'll come
back to that but let me not do that one
for the moment okay because that's a
giant story which I can't fit in today
that's yes your mind could be all over
the place okay so that's definitely the
case okay that's a good one yeah yeah
two great comments yeah you could say
like maybe this is a part of your brain
that goes with five things or something
this big versus this big now that's not
so interesting the part of your brain
that looks at something this big versus
this big but that's just as legitimate a
conclusion here right how about this
five different things versus only this
right there's a lot of different ways in
which you can say what is the mental
operation that I discovered in the human
brain in mind it all comes down to the
comparison so here's what they did to
try to do a better job they showed you
you know a more complicated thing that
doesn't mean anything a bunch of letters
that you can't pronounce a bunch of
letters that you can't pronounce but
it's not a real word and here's the real
word itself so if you want to say what
do you think this part of the mind is
doing what is what is that what part of
the mind is this part of the brain
allowed to happen in humans and only
humans on this planet and every word you
ever read only happens because this part
of the brain does what it does what is
that part of the brain doing is it so
simply responding to complicated things
five of them no not much okay a little
bit no not much
how about letters letters are pretty
interesting but there can't be a word by
English you can't pronounce this not too
interested a word a set of letters
you've never seen together before but
you can pronounce by their rules of
English boom right that's what I do
says this part of the brain by there
that's what I do okay I say I see
something and it's possibly a word and I
can say it by the rules of English and
by the way if it's a word I've done
before I do that too okay I'm pretty
flexible I can do new words I can do
words I've known before it matches what
you see with language that's reading
that's only our species can take our
visual system and the language we learn
as a child and put them together and
allow our our civilization to read and
this is the part of the brain where
those roads meet
and by the way we talked about local and
global the forest and the trees and
consistent with what we talked about in
split playing patients feeling and
global stuff right hemisphere you're
looking a local stuff left hemisphere so
we like it when the information we have
from split-brain patients or stroke
cushions aligns with healthy people
doing a task as they typically do
because then we sort of believe there's
something right about that so that's a
pet pretty good spatial resolution I
mean depends when you mean by good my
neuroscience colleagues you know this
miss everything we ever do is sort of
pathetically imprecise but five to ten
millimeter is not as good as fMRI the
temporal resolution is very poor we
cannot take one picture that lasts about
a minute an average is everything across
that you have to inject people with
radioactive stuff and and it's
correlational okay but it has one other
thing that's really really interesting
positron emission tomography because
you're injecting a radioactive label you
can create different kinds of labels
that go to different parts of the brain
so here's Parkinson's disease which we
know involves damage to the substantial
[ __ ] in the basal ganglia here's a
healthy person substantia [ __ ] and
here's a persons with Parkinson's
disease where these cells have died away
typically at least eighty percent of
these have to die before a person shows
Parkinson's disease symptoms clinically
here's an injection of a radioactive
stuff using pet that binds to dopamine
receiving neurons and you can see that
in the living Parkinson's patients this
tremendous reduction in these receptors
waiting for dopamine in a living patient
specifically dopamine receptors so
that's a disease here's here's why video
games are taking over the world oh no
not yet
we can do one more thing sorry we can
track a disease you know from a typical
person to a person with moderate
Parkinson's disease or severe so it's
not only within the disease we can see
differences creation but here's why
video games are taking over the world
because it would take a healthy person
young adults give them this kind of
dopamine binding tracer and have them
play a video game two things happen a
the parts of your brain that are
involved in reward dopamine is the
strongest reward neurotransmitter that
we know
things go crazy and what this graph is
showing you is the better you do the
more rewarded you are this is why you
will go for the next level okay cuz to
get that dopamine fix you got to keep
going alright
the better you are so I mean every room
and we think these reward mechanisms
underlying in many ways they relate to
everything you know why do you do
whatever you do because at some level in
some way you find a rewarding and and
the data is very compelling that way the
last method I'll talk about is
functional MRI and it's the one that's
obviously you know maybe most widely
visible so you sit in a scanner stimuli
are presented to you perform a task we
do a lot of stuff in our lab with
children we show them you know how the
frog would do it for those of you who've
done a functional MRI experiments there
were so many hands that were put up do
any of you want to say a word about your
experience doing that what was it like
easy huge fun recommend no not so much
fun it'll vary a little bit we said
noisy some people find a claustrophobic
yeah
oh so they didn't ask me to do a task
maybe who knows so the answer for the
student they were watching a movie and
not doing anything right and you were
you were doing yes or no clicks okay so
that would be a typical special MRI kind
of experiment some of them are more
obnoxious summer last summer funny some
are not as funny you're endlessly
pushing for things that are any other
experiences was it comfortable that's a
comfortable medium okay anybody else
want to share no okay so how does this
work so a functional MRI takes advantage
of MRI but when it focuses on hemoglobin
the stuff that carries oxygen in your
blood and it rests on the fact that
deoxyhemoglobin after oxygen has been
extracted as has is more sensitive to
them in a negative field and oxygen and
hemoglobin so it's like this here's your
here's a basically capillaries and veins
and arteries and veins and as as you go
through the capillary bed the smallest
vessels right neurons are extracting
oxygen to support their their physical
life what happens when this part of the
brain gets active is that more oxygen is
extracted to support the active neurons
so and we call this bold effect blood
oxygen level dependence so we're
measuring the change in blood changes
the ratio of oxygenated to deoxygenated
goldman's that changes the magnetic
field as we measure it and that's what
we directly measure that's not the
neurons so if the neurons are using up
oxygen why does it both signal increase
why does this ratio go up and because
intuitively you think it would go down
right because oxygen is being extracted
at a higher rate but here's what happens
there's if you look at oxygen being
extracted right after something happens
10 milliseconds there's a 10 seconds
there's a initial dip of oxygen that's
the neurons extracting the oxygen to
replenish themselves from their activity
their activity has been to give your
mind its life then what happens is
there's this vast oversupply for a much
longer time
you know this intuitively it's as if we
said it's so important to metabolically
support the neurons that make up our
minds that if we live to some areas
demanding a lot of blood we sent over
way too much extra as soon as we can
from a distance to make sure
everything's okay alright and because
our measurement is so sad we almost can
never measure this initial dip we almost
always measure this sustained oversupply
of oxygen to that part of the brain so
you could say it's such a house of cards
right the oversupply of the blood going
to a part of the brain changes a balance
of oxygenated to deoxygenated globin
that changes magnetic property and
that's how we've tried to figure out
what that part of the brain is doing for
your mind but it works pretty well in
some cases decent spatial resolution no
injection you can zoom in a scanner and
do a lot of different things
modest temporal resolution because it's
not milliseconds it's on the order of
seconds and it's correlational not
causal but you get some amazing results
I'm just gonna present to you at 2:00 or
3:00 um so here's one thing we're very
interested about humans is empathy right
how much we understand and feel other
people's happiness or sadness or pain so
the observation or imagination of
another person in a particular emotional
state automate automatically activates a
representation of that state the
observer empathy yeah and how do we
understand how another person feels and
we think that's a big thing and how we
were like to one another as humans so
the Tanya singer did the following
experiment
she said we talked about this before a
little bit embodied cognition that we
understand others out there by the
feelings we know within us we don't know
their feelings but we know our feelings
inside us right so here's what she did
she brought in pairs of people who were
friends or romantic partners okay pretty
close for us and she either had them get
some pain it was a shock within ethical
boundary okay but not pleasant okay
that's the pain or you got to watch
through a video camera while you're
being in
your partner getting the shock so think
about somebody you care about and think
about them getting something painful
okay and how you would feel at that
moment and they asked in the brain
what's similar and dissimilar and they
focus on with similar right now between
feeling paying yourself an observing
pain and somebody you care about
empathizing with the pain you see them
having and what they found is two areas
something of an anterior cingulate and
something in the insula which talked
about before where there was a lot of
overlap so this phrase I'm feeling your
pain in your brain when you feel for
somebody else's pain in this physical
sense you turn on some of the same brain
areas as when you feel physical pain
directly it's as if the basis to imagine
another person's feelings is a feelings
you know so well yourself okay and this
is literally shown now by the brain
imaging it could have been a story a
metaphor and arguments you know this is
scientific evidence that supports that
likelihood so we're gonna expand it in a
slightly fun way so there's been a lot
of study about in neuro economics
thinking about how we think about for
example things like trust so one game
and there's a number of them is called
the ultimatum game and many of you
probably know this but let me remind you
of this this version of it has two
players a proposer and a responder
and what they do is they give the
proposer a certain amount of money the
proposer
and and then the proposer is allowed to
make an offer to the responder if the
responder says no nobody gets any money
if the and usually people offer about
50% so let's make this concrete just for
a moment okay can I take you for a
second are you sorry you can decline
okay all right all right you're okay
okay you're right there okay so imagine
imagine if Tyler came up to me and gave
me ten dollars ten single dollars and I
said how would you feel if I gave you
five and I kept five would you come what
do you think might you go for it
I mean you go you're on $5 in your $5 a
head you know you know Tyler won't eat
this month because graduate student
stipends are modest but you know it is
it's a zero-sum game in the end okay so
okay okay so now Tyler comes over and
hands me ten more dollars and and I
offer you one
what's your first feeling assuming that
I wasn't your teacher great in you you
saw me get ten I say here's one
what's your feeling think about it yeah
now you don't have to buy a purely
economic perspective all right would you
be ahead by taking the dollar yeah okay
dollars a dollar two dollars or two
dollars right but people have a sense of
fairness okay even to their own
detriment if you offered two dollars
there and lower even knowing that you're
just ruining a dollar or two you would
have gotten for nothing except saying
yes people half the time will say no
right
it's like you are so unfair you were
saying to me I would never says you you
are so unfair
that you know we're gonna take us both
down but then you have the pleasure or
the $8 okay it's so unfair that my sense
of fairness is is disturbed okay okay
it's kind of it's an interesting way to
think about it somebody you know imagine
a friend of yours is handed $10 and they
offer you half and if you say no nobody
gets anything okay so you have tits a
trust game so they had the people in the
scanner playing this game with two
people they saw in a video monitor the
two people they're playing with our
setup okay the person in the scanner is
the real participant the people out
there they see our Confederates are to
play actors and one is a fair person
here's five dollars thank you here's
five dollars thank you okay here's six
dollars oh you're awesome you know we
can get along there's me and then
there's an unfair player here's a dollar
all right how about two dollars no no
and after a while you go I really the
fair player was very decent this unfair
player who you believe as part of the
experiment was a setup okay you're
thinking why is this person of such a
jerk they're constantly getting $10 into
constantly giving me one or two no no no
thank you all right now these people
yeah you get a shock
and you see these two strangers one of
whom was a wonderful fair player and one
of whom was an absurdly unfair player
you see them get a shock okay and they
had both men and women in the scanner
watching these things happen and here's
what happened and it's kind of funny but
you know for the women they had overlap
again between the parts of the brain
that turned on from here in the insula
when they got a shock and when either
the fair player got a shock or the
unfair player they felt bad for both by
this measure okay look at the men in the
study
I feel bad if the fair guy gets it sure
but this part of the brain is like yeah
give it to him can you push up the
voltage you know I mean it just came out
this way I know whether it would work
that way under all circumstances you
know all ages all societies other groups
of men and women don't know but in this
sample United Kingdom you know the man
had no empathy for the fire it's worse
than that
okay it's worse than they had no empathy
let me show you this if they asked to
indicate their desire for revenge
against this a behavioral response their
desire for revenge against the bad
player okay now they're not think they
pursued the unfair player down the
street and you know but just that
feeling like and a little bit the men
said yes you know let me only I could
take down this person there would be
great and here's the amazing thing we'll
come back to this structure called a
nucleus accumbens and sits in the bottom
of the basal of the basal ganglia it's
the structure that in the human brain is
most identified with reward and pleasure
most identified with reward and pleasure
by fMRI imaging look at the nucleus
accumbens when the unfair player gets
zapped okay you're watching the women
and that's not nothing much the men boom
big reward
revenge is rewarding in their brain okay
no sympathy and lots of revenge
satisfaction for the unfair player now
you can decide in your own life you know
who this applies to or not but it's kind
of sort of fun you sort of fun to
explore these different things how we
form ideas about empathy trust you know
whether they are in a society we give
them we grow up in somewhat different on
average and men and women huge ranges
within men huge Rangers alone so but
it's a sort of fun thing to explore so
let me end with something that's much
more
difficult and disturbing but another
place where imaging is giving us
insights that we could not have imagined
having some time ago so this is a very
difficult case I don't know if any of
you who've got through it I don't wish
it for you many of you some of you
probably have and many of you will
sometime in your life when you have to
make an end-of-life decision and amongst
the most famous of these cases oops
sorry
was um Terri Schiavo now I don't know if
you and then they mirin rings a bell for
you but it got very very famous amongst
these kinds of cases so she had a
cardiac arrest she took a lot of diet
pills and that may have contributed in
February 25th 1990 she went into a coma
and in a vegetative state
it's a vegetative state is when a person
seems to be kind of awake but when you
talk with them they're not very aware
they're not responsive they're not
noticing they're not talking but their
eyes are open and they're awake and eyes
are not closed so that's what she is and
they put in her a feeding tube because
without that she wouldn't live she
couldn't eat and feed herself
there was a heartbreaking difference of
opinion between her husband and her
parents her husband petitioned by some
years later actually eight years later
to remove the feeding tube and let her
pass away
the parents opposed that they said
that's not her wishes she would want to
keep on going with the feeding tube the
husband said no I don't believe that's
her wishes so you had this very tragic
confrontation between the parents who
loved her and the husband who presumably
loved her having different ideas about
what to do with her whether to end her
life or not
so finally her tube was removed but then
the parents went to court and the judge
reversed it and they put the tube back
in here she became sadly kind of back
and forth living nonliving on judicial
decisions her face case became
particularly famous for a bunch of
reasons and they it went back and forth
from court to court you know moving up
into state courts and there were several
US Supreme Court decisions about whether
to remove the tube or keep the tube in
and you know it's a tragic thing as a
tragic choice between the parents and
the husband it got to the US Congress
and the US Senate President Bush signed
a bill to keep her alive okay
I mean it was the highest everybody got
involved with various opinions
finally the Supreme Court made a series
of decisions
it was her it was disconnected in 2005
and she died in March 31 that year so
tragic difficult decision and a tragic
family situation that became kind of a
political and judicial football so
what's going on in the mind of somebody
like this and how could we even begin to
interpret it for a person who can't
speak for themselves and can't respond
so let me tell you about a different
case we don't know her case so here
again a vegetative state is one where
you appear to be awake but there's no
sign of awareness eyes are open but the
persons not talking or responding to
anything in their environment so here's
a different woman 23 years old in 2005
she had a road traffic accident severe
traumatic brain injury five months later
she's unresponsive but she has preserved
sleep-wake like she's waking on going to
sleep waking up when asleep eyes open
but unresponsive in every other way they
put her into an fMRI scanner as well as
healthy comparison people and they have
them due to mental imagery tasks okay
now because and they can't give in
street instructions to her but here's
what their history you go into scanner
and you're told to imagine two different
things playing tennis so imagine in your
mind's eye you playing tennis for a
moment imagine that or imagine visiting
all the rooms of your house starting
with your front door in the house that
you are living in now or where you grew
up imagine those things in your mind now
first of all just a pure cognitive
neuroscience level and we'll come back
to that imagination is a really
interesting thing and it turns out when
we imagine things again we use the parts
of our brain that does them imagination
is perception run backwards we can see
imagination in the human brain and
depending on what you're imagining you
use the same systems that you see with
if you imagine something you're looking
at you know will turn on your visual
system and it's even more specific than
that so let's first look at what happens
with the controls when they imagine
they're playing tennis they turn on the
supplementary motor area that's a part
of your brain that plans your physical
movements okay you're not moving but
you're thinking about it this is
imagination of movement when you plan a
movement you turn that on when you go
around your house you turn on spatial
areas that are in the pair of the
careful cortex and in a similar area
freyal cortex and purple cortex they're
turned on if we show you a moon
we were moving around in spaces if he
see spaces you turn those on if you
imagine spaces you turn them on so
imagination in the brain is perception
run backwards or physical action run
backwards you're not actually doing it
but look at this patient who got in the
scanner
who's non-responsive you read heard the
instructions and you see what she does
and look at her brain asked to imagine
tennis ask to imagine the rooms in her
house it looks just like that what does
that mean just in a common sense what
does it mean did she understand the
instruction at some level yes right she
she wouldn't turn on those parts of the
brain if she didn't understand
understand understand the instruction
she imagines the thing you asked her to
instruct so this got in the front page
of the New York Times the fMRI could
tell you the internal mental life of a
person he could no longer speak or
communicate in any other way now it's
turned out since then that when they put
in other patients into the scanner most
of them don't show this pattern okay so
it's not that every patient in a
vegetative state is full of mental life
like this person and in a deeper way we
don't really understand what this mental
life is like we don't know whether she
simply understands some things but
doesn't have feelings or plans or
desires or whether she has those two
okay we didn't understand really the
full range of mental life but we didn't
know we know that she can understand an
instruction and her brain follows
through with it okay
most patients it turns out don't look
like that in vegetative States so again
brain imaging has taken us inside the
mind of somebody who cannot communicate
for themselves and let us say something
about what it is that's going on in that
mind so in conclusion we talked about
different ways of learning about the
brain different methods to record
structure and function that vary in
their temporal and spatial acuity and
you know incredibly different ways in
which we can understand the organization
and time and space of how the brain
supports the human mind Thanks
you
you